[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing none other than peeves
the poltergeist now if you're purely a
moviegoer
then that name may not mean much to you
as peeves was actually a character
who was omitted from the films
altogether but if you've read the books
then you understand the significance of
peaves and you may be wondering
what happened to him why didn't he make
it into the films
in my opinion the omission of peeves may
have been the largest
single overt omission from the film
series though peeves isn't
entirely integral to the plot his name
is mentioned a fair bit in the book
series
and i find it interesting that they
would remove him entirely
i mean why not have him if you aren't
already privy to peeves
he is hogwarts infamous poltergeist not
to be confused with ghosts
poltergeists are essentially
indestructible spirits of chaos
the name poltergeist is german in origin
and
roughly translates as noisy ghost
although it is not
strictly speaking a ghost at all the
poltergeist is an invisible entity that
moves objects
slams doors and creates other audible
kinetic disturbances
it has been expressed that peeves has
existed at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry
since its inception in 990 a.d
he purportedly came with the building
since then
peeves has remained at the school
terrorizing people
namely the school caretakers in fact
peeves has terrorized every school
caretaker
since hankerton humble the school's
founding caretaker
and in more recent years has been a
thorn in the side of argus filch
though unconfirmed many have speculated
that peeves
is actually a manifestation or
personification
of the student's mischief making
hogwarts the perfect residence
peeves is the most notorious and
troublesome poltergeist in british
history
unlike the overwhelming majority of his
colleagues peeves has a physical form
though he is able to become invisible at
will his looks reflect his nature
which those who know him would agree is
a seamless blend of humor
and malice okay so peeves has existed at
the school
since its inception actively fought
against the bad guys
and appeared in every book what gives
well it turns out that they did try to
put peeves in the films
at least the first film they just ran
into some issues
in fact actor rick male played the part
of peeves but before the film was
released his scenes were cut
male a legendary british comedic actor
never explained the reasoning for why
his role was cut
but did mention in an interview that his
jokes caused distractions on set
apparently he kept giving all of the
extras the giggles
male would have been the perfect actor
to portray peeves
who was loved by fans so it's a shame
that he never made it into the films
the peeves from the books will have to
be enough for us and that's it for this
video
did you know about peeves did you know
that they filmed his scenes let me know
in the comment section
below until next time oh potter you
rotter oh what have you done
you're killing off students and think
it's great fun
[Music]
you